listen  i'm so sorry but  my show ain't ready  breaking this afternoon an emotional  adele posting a video to social media  saying that all of her dates for her las  vegas residency will be rescheduled good  afternoon and thank you so much for  joining us here at four o'clock i'm  christian costas i'm kirstjen joyce  weekends with adele scheduled to begin  tomorrow at the coliseum at caesar's  palace the singer had two shows lined up  each weekend through mid-april in the  video posted just over an hour ago adele  blames delivery delays she also says  half of her crew and team are down with  covid and they just haven't been able to  pull the show together there were no  specifics given on the new dates just  that more information would be coming  soon